I just want to go through it quickly and
give each one of you a chance just pick
one thing that you feel is a challenge
that we should overcome in and then say
something about what you feel is the
best thing we can do right now to try to
mitigate it well someone who's outside
this field I think the challenge I'm
really in touch with is how hard it is
to take the safety concerns emotionally
seriously and I add how hard it is for
people in the field to do that as well I
can't tell you how many people outside
this room who purport to be experts
think the control problem is a total
non-issue it's just it's flabbergasting
to meet these people and just and
therefore not worth thinking about and
one of the reasons I think is that in
the one case there's there's this
illusion that that the time horizon
matters the if you feel that this is 50
or 100 years away that is totally
consoling but there's an implicit
assumption there the the assumption is
that you know how long it will take to
build this safely and that 50 or 100
years is enough time the other issue is
I think most people feel like
intelligence is an intrinsic good and of
course we want more of it and and it's
very easy to be in touch with that
assumption because right now there's a
cure for cancer which we have not
discovered right at how galling is that
and but for more intelligence but but
for knowing which experiments to run or
how to integrate the data we already
have in hand we would we would have a a
cure for cancer that was actionable now
unless there was some physical law of
the universe that prevented us from
curing cancer which seems unlikely so it
the the pain of not having enough
intelligence is is really excruciating
when you when you focus on it but and I
think to your previous question of doing
this quickly becomes an intrinsic good
provided we have solved the alignment
problems and the political problems and
the chaos that would that would follow
if we were just if we did it quickly
without solving those problems so I
think it's
the thing that is alarming is how
ethereal these concerns are even to
those who have no rational argument
against them so some it's it sounds to
me like you're agreeing very strongly
what Shayne legs said that there is and
some circles are still the strong taboo
that you know don't even think consider
the possibility that we might get AGI
because it's just absolutely ridiculous
and he was arguing that the sooner we
can get rid of this Tabo the the sooner
people can get to work and find all
these really helpful solutions and
answers that we need so suppose for a
moment that I came up to you and I said
to you that this idea of superhuman
intelligence sounds absolutely
ridiculous it sounds completely nuts and
by the way I've never seen your TED talk
you know and we're in an elevator you
have only 30 seconds to persuade me to
take this more seriously but would you
say and well a lot of people who are
here will have this exact conversation
with colleagues and others and what well
there there are very few assumptions you
need to make to take this seriously
intellectually again the emotional part
is a separate piece but if you assume
that intelligence is just on some level
the product of information processing in
a physical system and there are very few
people who dispute that in who are
scientifically literate at this point
and you assume that we will continue to
improve our information processing
systems unless something terrible
happens to us to prevent that and that
seems like a very safe assumption then
it is just a matter of time before we
instantiate something that is human
level and beyond in in our computers and
again the time horizon is only consoling
on the assumption that we know we have
enough time to solve the alignment
problems and the political problems that
we examine the other thing is it's
humbling here that Rey brought up at one
point is that even if we were handed a
perfectly been benign well behaved AI
just from God you know we're given a
perfect Oracle we're given a perfect
inventor of of good technology given our
current political and economic
atmosphere we would that would produce
total chaos we just have not we don't
have the the the ethical or political
will to share the wealth we don't have
the the political integration to deal
with the you know the this thing being
given to Silicon Valley and not being
given at the same moment to China or
Iran so there's just it's it's it's
alarming that the best-case-scenario
currently you know basically just
ripping out 80% of Nyx book because
we've solved all those problems is still
a terrifying one and there so clearly
that's a near-term thing that we have to
solve thank you so Dennis you want to
tell us about one thing that you feel is
a challenge and and and say something
about what we should focus on now yeah I
think I collect I think it's you know I
agree with with with both statements
already said that so I think the
coordination problem is one thing where
you know we want to we want to avoid
this sort of harmful race to the finish
where you know corner-cutting starts
happening and things like safety easy
things to you know we'll get where
things will get cut because obviously
they don't necessarily directly
contribute to AI capability fact they
may hold it back a bit by making a safe
AI so I think that's that's going to be
a big issue on a global scale and seems
like I know that's going to be a hard
problem when we're talking about
national governments and things and I
think also you know we haven't thought
enough about the whole governance
scenario of how do we want you know
those AIS to be out in the world how
many of them and how they know who will
set their goals all these kinds of
things I think needs a lot more thought
you know is that once we've already
solved the technical problem
the three overlapping revolutions of
people talk about GNR genetics biotech
nanotechnology in robotics which is AI
and their bit there are proposals there
was the CL mark conferences done here
decades ago for biotech that have worked
fairly well there are similar proposals
for nanotechnology there's a difference
with AI in that there really isn't a
foolproof technical solution to this you
can have technical controls on say
nanotechnology one of the guidelines is
it shouldn't be self-replicating it's
not really realistic because it can't
scale to meaningful quantities without
being self-replicating but you can
imagine technical protections if you
have an AI that's more intelligent than
you and it's out for your destruction or
it's out for the world's destruction and
there's no other AI but superior to it
that's a bad situation so that's that's
the specter and partly this is amplified
by our observation of what we as humans
the most intelligent species on the
planet have done to other species if we
look at how we treat animals people you
know are very for it like their dogs and
pets but if you look at factory farming
were not very benign to species that are
less intelligent than us that that's
gender engenders a lot of the concern we
see that if there's a new ant type of
entity that's more intelligent than us
that's kind of treat us like we've
treated other species so that's the
concern that you know I do think what
we're doing at this conference is
appropriate I I wanted to mention that I
think we should publish these guidelines
the way the Asilomar guidelines in
biotech were published decades ago and
then people can and people can you can
have an opt-in opt-out but I think we
should actually say we had this
conference and the a i''k leadership
community you know has come up with
these guidelines and people can respond
to them and
debate them and then maybe the next
conference will provides them you sell
them our biotech guidelines have been
revised many times but I would advocate
we actually take a stand and put forth
of these guidelines and then let the
whole community at large debate them and
have them be have them guide our
research it's actually worked quite well
in biotech well I mean trying to think
of like you know what what what is an
actual good future what does that
actually look like or at least bad or
and how you want to characterize it
because it to the point that was made
earlier I think maybe but maybe my
salmon and vilest that we're headed
towards either superintelligence or
civilization ending those are those like
the two things that are like that
that'll happen it intelligence will keep
advancing I don't think they would for
advancing this is something that puts so
ization into stasis or destroy any
civilization so then we better figure
out what is the world that would we
would like to be in where there is this
digital super intelligence
think the another point that I think is
really important to appreciate is that
we are all of us already our sidewalks
so you have a machine extension of
yourself in the form of you your phone
and your computer and all your
applications you are already superhuman
but by far you have more more powerful
capability then press in the United
States had you know 30 years ago if you
have an internet link you have an Oracle
of wisdom you can communicate to
millions of people communicate to the
rest of earth instantly I mean these are
magical powers that didn't exist not
that long ago so everyone is already
superhuman and as I walk the limitation
is one of bandwidth so we're bandwidth
constrained particularly on output so
our input is much better but our output
is extremely slow and if you want to be
generous you could say maybe it's a few
hundred bits per second or a kilobyte or
something like that output but you know
the way we we output is like me about
little meat sticks that we moves very
slowly and and push buttons or tap tap a
little screen I and that's just
extremely slow and you know compare that
to a computer which can communicate at
the terabyte level it's a very big
orders 92 differences that our input is
much better because of vision but even
that could be enhanced significantly I
think I think the
the two things that are needed for look
for a good future that we would look at
and concluded is good most likely is
would we have to solve that bandwidth
constraint with it with a direct neural
interface I think a high bandwidth
interface to the cortex so that we can
have a digital tertiary layer that's
more full of more fully symbiotic with
with the rest of us like we've got look
at the cortex and the limbic system
which seems to work together pretty well
they've got good bandwidth whereas the
bandwidth to a digital toshi layer is is
weak so I think if we can solve that
bandwidth issue and then AI could be
widely available yeah add the analogy to
nuclear bomb is not exactly correct it's
it's not it's not as those gonna explode
and create a mushroom cloud it's more
like if if there were just a few people
that had it but if they would be able to
bees
essentially dictate dictators of earth
or you know whoever acquired it and and
and if it was limited to just one of
people there and it was ultra smart they
were they would have dominion over earth
so I think it's extremely important that
it be widespread and that we solve the
bandwidth issue and if we do those
things then
we'll be tied to our consciousness tied
to our will type the sum of individual
human will and and everyone would have
it so we sort of stole a relatively even
playing field in fact it would be
probably more egalitarian than today